k alexis poulain nos éditorialistes et
puis aussi nicolas vidal directeur de
publication de putsch médias bonsoir à
vous alors visiblement on a des
estimations mais on va s'intéresser à
l'enjeu l'un des enjeux principaux de ce
second tour des régionales et
départementales il s'agit du taux
d'abstention encore très fort
probablement un taux record encore ce
soir bien en dessous de 2015 puisque à
17 heures il était de 27 89%
alexis plaint pas de sursaut
démocratique
pas vraiment non on a vu pourtant une
semaine un ouf chaque appareil a essayé
de mobiliser les troupes et même au delà
en disant qu'il fallait sans doute se
réveiller qu'il y avait une élection
régionale même si certains ne le savait
pas il ya eu le scandale de la
distribution des prospectus électoraux
par adrexo qui est qui a fait un flop
le peu de communication autour de cette
élection et puis quand même une semaine
où on a beaucoup parlé entre dans
l'autre d'auto de de ceux qui allaient
s'affronter pour ce second tour donc je
pense qu'il ya eu un micro sursaut mais
rien en comparaison de ce qui était
attendu
les français continuent de bouder les
urnes massivement avec je pense à un
rejet de ce jeu de politique où la voix
ne compte pas ou qu'on peut dans un
système où l'offre politique ne paraît
pas répondre à la demande donc il ya
toute une réflexion qui n'a pas été fait
un par la classe politique qui pensent
que le problème c'est la façon de voter
qu'il faudrait faire le vote
électronique le vote par correspondance
va rendre le vote obligatoire même
parfois mais pas la question sur
pourquoi aujourd'hui un tel désamour de
des électeurs des citoyens qui ont le
droit de vote face à une classe
politique qui a finit finalement sa mue
avec ceux en même temps ma chronique qui
s faire la jonction entre le parti
socialiste les l air pour faire ce parti
qui n'existe plus la république en
marche qui n'est pas là dans aucun des
scrutins qui a pris encore une défaite
lors du premier tour et donc maintenant
je pense que les électeurs attendent
sans doute des offres beaucoup plus
clair peut-être aussi des offres de
changement de rupture par rapport à une
politique qui est la même depuis
quarante ans que ce soit de gauche ou de
droite
que ce soit sur la feuille de route
européenne que ce soit sur la moins
disant social la façon dont on aussi
maltraite l'éducation nationale beaucoup
de choses à dire mais qui fait que au
delà de l'intérêt qu'il peut y avoir
dans la chose publique il ya vraie d
amour par rapport à l'offre à l'offre
politique
alors certains diront du côté politique
que c'est la preuve que tout va bien
finalement puisque si les français ne
vont pas voter c'est qu'ils n'ont pas le
besoin
je dirais plutôt la reverse je crois que
c'est c'est plutôt un symptôme d'une
démocratie défaillante
en tout cas malgré les appels de l'aisne
l'ensemble de la classe politique à se
mobiliser pour ce second tour les
français nicolas vidal ont boudé comme
le dit si bien alexis poulain les urnes
ah oui vous avez raison ce montage quand
même c'est un acte politique je l'avais
dit déjà dimanche dernier c'est un
véritable acte politique
encore une nouvelle fois on nous avait
expliqué la semaine dernière qu'il y
avait toute une série de raisons qui
faisait que les gens n'aient pas été
voter les régionales on savait pas trop
ce qu'est ce que c'est il y avait passé
le bureau de vote est aujourd'hui une
nouvelle fois c'est le retour de bambou
qui viennent taper une seconde fois vous
savez c'est comme la paire de j
il a une épine à 2 et ce soir c'est
absolument je le dis assez souvent c'est
un séisme politique
alors on entendu alexis l'a dit tout à
l'heure mais on a entendu tous les
partis les grands médias meanstream il
dit oui il faut aller voter il faut
aller voter même facebook a fait des
petits dans cars pour dire aller voter
c'est les élections et où les gens ne
veulent plus voter les gens ne croient
plus la politique je les ai déjà dit
lundi dernier ce n'est pas un tricheur a
là ni vous avez toujours 25% pêcheurs à
la ligne
mais finalement ce soir c'est une
insurrection populaire silencieuse qui
continue à faire mal rappelez-vous
samantha les municipales nous a expliqué
avec près de 60% d'abstention que
c'était le qu'ovide aujourd'hui on
arrive aux régionales c'est le second
tour nous sommes le 27 juin au soir et
les gens nous croit sinon on put à la
politique nous aurons le temps de
décrypter tous ces résultats
mais très sincèrement c'était un vrai
vrai séisme politique et quand je vois
des candidats même si là que
d'estimations arrivée fier comme artaban
à leur qg
l'esprit ravi pour ceux qui vont
remporter les régions très sincèrement
c'est effrayant c'est navrant de voir
une telle des connexions de nos élites
politiques voilà pour ce préambule d'un
de ses premières estimations
alors on en a encore des premières
estimations
on va pas les commenter tout de suite on
va attendre un petit peu
alex et poulain mais c'est vrai que
c'est ces élections régionales
départementales en nous les présentait
finalement comme des élections test
avant l'échéance que tous les français
attendent la présidentielle et 2022
finalement qu'est-ce que cela dit sur
l'échéance à venir selon vous alors
c'est déjà une volonté de l'exécutif
d'avoir nationalisé ce scrutin en
envoyant autant de ministres à faire
campagne ministres qui ont été sortis
dès le premier tour 10 compris le musée
la justice par exemple eric dupond
moretti dans le nord donc ce choix-là de
vouloir nationaliser ces élections alors
qu'elle était régionale a été un fiasco
pourrait mener le maquereau et on voit
bien que
il ya eu un rejet des listes république
en marche massif
comparé aux partis traditionnels qui eux
gardent leurs bases puisque les régions
leur appartenait avant la création de la
république en marche donc ce parti créé
par emmanuel macron ce mouvement ne
s'ancre pas ni dans les villes ni dans
les territoires que sont les régions les
départements il est imparti parisiens
hors sol un partie d'entre eux soit de
politique politicienne donc ça c'est la
première chose ensuite il ya un peu la
prime aux sortants c'est à dire qu'on va
voter pour ceux qu'on connaît il ya des
équipes qui gèrent aux régionales et on
a très peu parlé des enjeux finalement
au niveau des régions on a parlé d'
enjeu de sécurité
on a parlé de toutes sortes de choses
mais rarement finalement de ce que
faisait la région et qu on avait des
candidats aussi vous avez montré le qg
de campagne de xavier bertrand qui sont
des candidats déclarés à l'élection
présidentielle et qui eux veulent
utiliser ce scrutin pour en faire une
marche vers l'or
leur passage ou leur chemin vers la
victoire ou la défaite néanmoins dans le
chemin vers 2022 c'est le cas clairement
de xavier bertrand mais on attend de
voir quels seront les déclarations de
valérie pécresse en fonction des scores
dans la soirée et puis aussi laurent
wauquiez qui reste très silencieux en ce
début d'année mais qui compte bien peser
sur la campagne de 2000 plantes a donné
la parole à l'issue d'un très rapidement
à un nicolas vidal et puis on va
poursuivre parce qu'on a vu évidemment
les résultats partiels la carte de ces
élections comme en train dé videmment
ses résultats nicolas vidal alexis
poulain pointe est justement la
responsabilité de l'exécutif dans la
volonté de vouloir nationaliser ces
élections mais aussi le rôle des médias
qui présentait effectivement aussi cette
élection comme un test est comme avoir
aussi le duel est reine et
la reine aussi donc qu'est-ce que cela
dit à ce niveau ah ben moi j'ai lu ce
matin le l'édito natacha polony concert
de marianne extrêmement intéressant si
le mea culpa médiatique je crois qu'il
ya un vrai mea culpa médiatique pour la
plupart des grands médias d'ailleurs ce
soir j'écoutais avant de prendre
l'antenne sur arte des gens qui étaient
très surpris des grains de riz qui était
très surpris finalement et même parfois
vais vous dire un peu d'inquiétude si
ces gens parce que je le dis c'est une
insurrection populaire silencieuse et
donc effectivement les médias aussi les
grands médias mais ce qu'ils m'ont pas
forcément jouer leur os aux sélections
là alex il a dit on a nationalisé latu
bon emmanuel mâcon concrètement les
régionales pour lui c'est une fête
foraine il s'en moquait concrètement dès
demain matin il va repartir en campagne
mais aujourd'hui effectivement les
grands médias vous savez c'était
peut-être de déconnexion ce que
j'appelle souvent l'élite l'élite
politico médiatique qui sont
complètement déconnectés les gens et
puis on entendu des as his totalement
farfelue je le disais le dimanche
dernier il ya eu celui qui nous et qui
avait passé deux bureaux de vote
aujourd'hui on eu toute une série de
choses finalement les français les
absents ont toujours tort je les entends
du sang fois aujourd'hui finalement donc
on voit bien comment donner même les
grands médias parisien a une nouvelle
fois parisien des grands médias
meanstream je précise
eh ben ils ont ils sont tout aussi
déconnectée de ces élections et surtout
de cette insurrection populaire des
français qui n'ont pas les beautés parce
que c'est un acte politique
il n'était pas à la plage de france et
ils ne vont pas voter parce qu'ils ne
veulent plus voter et participer à ce
que pelé marcel gaucher ce théâtre des
ombres
voilà où on en est ce soir et que je le
redis c'est un séisme politique
on va se retrouver en revanche est
commentée pour regarder ensemble
peut-être les résultats partiels cette
carte à forte dominante rose donc avec
la gauche qui s'impose dans certaines
régions et la droite aussi qui s'impose
également on voit que pour le
rassemblement national ça semble pliée
en dans la région paca on attend
toujours les résultats aussi pour l'île
de france une région aussi importante
pour les républicains on va revenir sur
toutes ces estimations à 20h30 pour
faire un point complet ce sera lors de
notre
dition spéciale consacrée à ces
élections avec vous alexis poulin et
nicolas vidal